Kit Harington doesn't miss Game of
Thrones yet I'm so protective over this
show now I'm so I'm so fond of it and as
it gets towards the end all these
exciting things happen which I want to
be shocks for people the 32 year old
covers the January February issue of GQ
Australia and inside the mag he opens up
about being pushed to the limit filming
the show's eighth and final season quote
the last season of Thrones seemed to be
designed to break us everyone was broken
at the end I don't know if we were
crying because we were sad it was ending
or if we were crying because it was
soaking tiring the actor added we were
sleep-deprived it was like it was
designed to make you think right I'm
[ __ ] sick of this I remember everyone
walking around towards the end going
I've had enough now I love this it's
been the best thing in my life
I'll miss it one day but I'm done you
better get to work Jon Snow
[Music]
after nearly a decade of playing John
snow Harrington says he's most looking
forward to the monotony of everyday life
quote I think people who don't work in
film or TV don't realize quite how
disorientating it is being away from
home all the time after nine years I'll
be at home in one place
static he's also looking forward to
spending time with his new wife Rose
Leslie whom he met on the show I think
that's the really special thing about it
is that we we met on this show and this
is madness such a special thing I'm so
so privileged the two played love
interests on the HBO series what do you
like goes whose food Jon Snow Spider
save me Jon Snow quote it dawned on me
recently and I have no idea if we will
but say me and Rose do have children
they'll know they'll be able to see the
genesis of their parents getting
together which is quite a wonderful
thought really I think the show for
everything but more than anything else I
think it for introducing me to her the
first footage of Game of Thrones final
season was released this week it's just
a seconds long teaser showing Sansa
Stark played by sophie turner meeting
Daenerys Targaryen played by Emilia
Clarke Winterfell is you okay
well the clip didn't reveal much
director David Nutter recently promised
DT that it'll live up to the height but
play coy about those much speculated
character deaths quote it was the first
time that I was able to actually direct
the premiere episode of the season so
I'm just nervous hopefully the audience
will like it starting season 8 but I'm
very confident that they will and he
added I know that I can say this if
you're a fan of the show you will be
completely satisfied by where the series
goes to they've really done a tremendous
job in servicing the drama and the
characters and so forth and there are
many ups and down
and twists and turns all across the game
of throne Society
[Music]
[Applause]